change  ah the bishop on c6 is protected that's  the  that's the kind of small little detail  but i don't think that it really decides  anything so c4 ab5  bishop takes a5 and  911 wants to use some trick  but  i mean i i don't see the big trick  because i would really love to take on  a4 but but queen b6 and here i first  thought like wow here is the knight d7  option but then we can fall back queen  before and after bishop f8 we move back  all the way to d2 and uh and we win the  queen so yeah he this is what happens  after a6 c4 takes a b5 bishop a5 and b  takes c4  it's amazing how love has found a way to  still keep things going and keep the  game going the feeling was and you know  for mere mortals well like myself if i  land myself in such a position out of  the open